sex I think it's gonna stick around that
was an innovation that actually came
along with death before sexual
reproduction cells were immortal they
never died they would reproduce
asexually I think will keep the sex and
get rid of the death sexuality has
become a form of communication and it's
obviously a rich area of human activity
and communication we have already
separated sexuality from largely from
its biological reproduction we can have
reproduction without sex we can
certainly have sex without reproduction
so we've already kind of isolated it as
a communication medium and in that
regard it's it's important I think all
these technologies enhance our ability
to communicate and sexuality has always
been an important part of new media
technologies virtual reality will be an
opportunity to expand all kinds of human
relationships including physical
essential and sexual ones which very
soon are going to become full immersion
with 3d TV and things like Project
connect from Microsoft where the
computer can pick up your movement or
we're gonna be in the action you're not
just gonna be watching virtual reality
you know here on a little screen it's
going you're gonna be in it and there
won't be this cartoon like thing we have
now it will be very realistic we've had
some technologies where you can change
who you are you can wear a different
fashion but we're gonna have much more
flexibility if you could really change
your whole body so it can be just a game
or it can be an educational experience
or it can be a different way to have
relationships